Congress has appropriated and given
eighty million dollars to the State
Department which is of course run by
Russia connected friend of Vladimir
Putin Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
the point of that eighty million dollars
was to fight Russian propaganda and
misinformation uh oh I could see how
this could be a little bit problematic
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson is not
interested in using that money
why doesn't Rex want to use that money
well according to a former senior State
Department official in a conversation
with Politico Tillerson spokesman Arcee
Hammond suggested to Tillerson that
actually using the 80 million to counter
Russian disinformation and propaganda
would make Moscow very angry this money
came from a project last year initially
meant to counter Isis propaganda and it
then expanded to include Russia in light
of the meddling in our election dating
back to February State Department
officials were trying to get Tillerson
to use the sixty million dollars from
the Pentagon Department of Defense that
were allocated 20 million more that were
allotted within the State Department
that's a total of 80 million dollars
some of this money will straight-up
expire if it is not transferred soon by
Tillerson this is crazy Pat this would
be like the Pentagon turning down 80
million dollars to protect the United
States right after 9/11 I mean Russia
just attacked the sovereignty and
independence of our elections with a
very powerful and well-crafted and
calculated and executed disinformation
and information warfare campaign until
ursins got eighty million dollars
available to try to prevent that from
happening in the future
and according to his spokesperson he
doesn't want to do it because it might
anger the people were trying supposedly
to protect ourselves from and it's not
like Tillerson is in control of the
budget and you know bringing these funds
out from some other role that the State
Department could play yeah I mean
Congress is footing the bill here and he
has every decision as to how strongly he
wants to execute this plan right whether
he wants to really go anti Russia or
just a little bit I'm sort of confused
because Russia used to be afraid of
angering the United States and now we've
got the strong leader in the White House
who's going to get things done and it
seems he's the one who's afraid of
angering Russia
have really changed and this is only
part of the disaster by the way that is
a Tillerson State Department there are
200 unfilled senior positions in the
State Department Tillerson also has said
that he's not happy about this new
Russian sanctions bill which prevents
trump from preventing new sanctions or
from list with the lifting existing
sanctions on Russia if Russia isn't
creating this propaganda as Vladimir
Putin claims then why would this anger
the Russian government right if you're
Russia and you're like yeah we're not
doing any of this stuff we're accused of
doing then you would kind of not really
be affected by the State Department
trying to prevent future interference
because you're not doing any
interference and Tillerson has a role in
this being the former CEO of ExxonMobil
I mean they had a five hundred billion
dollar deal in the works with Russia
oh yeah sanctions are going to get in
the way of that and remember Tillerson
got that Russian order of friendship I
mean that's going to have to be null and
void at this point the picture that's
over my shoulder here I believe is from
when Rex Tillerson received the Russian
order of friendship medal from Vladimir
Putin and he's wearing that medal there
and shaking hands with the filthy-rich
Russian leader Wow quite an interesting
picture this folks this man right here
who has just been awarded in this
picture a medal of friendship by
Vladimir Putin that is our Secretary of
State rejecting 80 million dollars to
prevent Russia from interfering in
future elections let's take a break
we'll talk to Terry Cogan law professor
Kari Cogan next about Donald Trump's
attempt to ban transgender military
servicemembers today's program is made
possible in part by Gamefly which is
sort of like netflix for video games
they've got over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can also stream games you don't even
need a gaming console or a computer
because you can stream games through
your Amazon fire stick or Roku box and
then use your mobile phone as the
controller you can play as many games as
you want for one monthly fee and if you
find some games you
to keep you can buy them for a low used
price never with due dates or late fees
and our audience can get a 30-day free
trial at Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s
the games are shipped directly to you
with return envelopes included no
contracts and you can also stream the
games I think I mentioned that you can
also rent games through the mobile app
get a free 30-day trial for david pakman
show viewers and listeners and support
our show at Gamefly offer.com forward
slash TDP s